Simone Biles is back two years ago.
The most decorated gymnast
of all time
stepped away from the sport
to see to her mental health needs.
Maybe this video that much more welcome
seeing her back in action
practicing for this weekend's competition
near Chicago
her first since the 2021 Tokyo Olympics.
And her last opportunity
to qualify for the U.S.
Gymnastics Championship
Championships later this month.
That's an important step
on the way to the 2024 Paris games.
More now from CNN's Carolyn Marno.
I guess I would describe myself
as confident
flying high
after five Olympic medals in 2016 in Rio
and an unprecedented ascension
to the top of the sport.
I'm always in all when I watch her
sometimes I just think she's un human
just because she's just so amazing.
Simone Biles
life took an unexpected detour that fall.
USA Gymnastics was rocked
by revelations
of sexual abuse from longtime team
doctor Larry Nassar.
Biles went public
with her own story in 2018
tweeting a statement which read in part
I know that this horrific experience
does not define me
at the 2021 Tokyo games.
With the world
anticipating
another superhuman performance,
Biles showed her strength
outside of the competition
suffering from what she describes
as the twisties,
inexplicably losing her
bearings in the air.
The girls tell me in training,
my coaches saw me in training
like I physically couldn't do it safely,
and it's
because I was getting so lost in the air.
The superstar gymnast withdrew
from five events
at the Tokyo games,
prioritizing her mental health
over her medal count
to bring the topic of mental health.
I think
it should be talked about a lot more,
especially with athletes,
because I know
some of us are going through
the same things
and we're always told to push through it.
After returning home from Tokyo,
an emotional Biles
testified before the Senate
Judiciary Committee about the FBI's
handling of the sexual abuse
case against Nassar.
To be clear, I blame Larry Nassar,
and I also blame
an entire system
that enabled and perpetrated his abuse.
Biles says she's been in therapy weekly
since stepping away.
Now she's ready for a comeback.
This weekend
marks her first
elite competition since 2021.
She's aware of how influential
she continues to be
at the end of the day.
We're not just entertainment.
We're humans.
And there are things
going on behind the scenes
that we're also trying to juggle
with as well.
On top of sports
league gymnastics has helped
shape me and the people around by.
I'm really excited about life
and what's to come
and how I've changed and evolved
as a person.
Pamela I'm told that Biles is planning
on competing
in four events
in the Saturday's Core
Hydration Classic,
which has been sold out for weeks
ever since this news broke,
that she would be
coming back to the sport
and her return to elite
competition is also widely viewed
as the first step towards
a potential return
to the Olympic stage
that would be in Paris
in the summer of 2024.
Pamela. Well, all right.
Thanks so much.
Joining us
now, sportscaster
and CNN contributor Bob Costas.
How exciting is this, Bob,
this return of Simone Biles?
And what will you be watching for
this weekend?
Well, it's very exciting.
She's the best of all time
by acclamation.
There's really no dispute.
Some athletes establish their position.
Historic Ali,
cumulatively,
even if she never competed
in another Olympics,
what she did in Rio in 2016
at the age of 19,
not just winning the events,
but executing maneuvers
that other gymnasts couldn't even try,
let alone do half as well.
She was by acclimation the best ever.
Now when we talk about the twisters,
as Carolyn mentioned,
there are a number
of overlapping aspects here.
And that also connects to mental health.
There's the abuse from Larry Nassar.
There's all the pressure
put upon her as the face,
with all due respect
to Katie Ledecky and others
expected to be
the American face of the Tokyo Olympics
and those expectations.
And then there's
the mind body disconnect
that may or may not
be affected by mental stress.
But it stands to reason that it does,
at least to some extent,
that it played a role.
And it's just too dangerous
when you have that disconnect.
You could sustain
significant bodily injury.
So all those things came into play
at once in Tokyo.
Now, the best to ever do it is back.
Assuming she can qualify
for the Olympic team
and there's something else here, Pamela.
Nothing against Tokyo
as a site for an Olympics,
but we know
that it was in the midst of COVID
and there were
no spectators in the stands.
That also applied in large part
to Beijing.
But there were also misgivings
about the IOC
going back to Beijing for a second time.
And all the human rights implications.
So a lot of the joy
that surrounded
the Olympics wasn't there.
Now, this is a chance for the Olympics
to get its mojo back.
Paris, what a wonderful setting
and an American audience.
I think we'll look forward to this
more than the last few Olympics.
And among the reasons will be
that Simone Biles
is possibly back on that Olympic stage.
Yes.
She creates so much of the anticipation.
Right.
And as we know, Bob,
since the Tokyo Olympics,
I mean, she's gotten married.
She's building a life with her husband.
What are the benefits
but also the challenges
for a dominant athlete like Simone Biles
taking that kind of break
from competition
Well, everyone's
individual circumstance is different.
I think she needed that time away.
It's pretty clear.
I haven't been in touch with Simone
for a while.
But I knew her pretty well
since I hosted the Olympics
in 2016 and kept track of her
leading up to that.
And subsequently,
we were at events together.
She's a very bright young woman.
It should be said that this is clearly
the last go around.
27 is an advanced age for a modern
Olympic gymnast.
Katie Ledecky,
the other most
famous American Olympian,
will be 27 next year as well.
But that's not such an advanced
age for a swimmer.
So Simona was 19 when she did it in Rio.
She'll be 27 assuming she gets to Paris.
And we'll see what she's
capable of doing.
But it's pretty clear
that she needed the time off
just to get herself together
in every respect.
And then prime herself
for what may happen a year
from now in Paris.
Yeah,
she just had so much courage
to be as open as she was
to take the time she needed. Right.
And she did receive backlash.
Some backlash,
of course, for her decision in Tokyo.
But she also received a lot of praise
for putting her safety
and her mental health first.
How impactful is her voice
among this generation
of athletes and beyond?
I think it is impactful, as is
Michael Phelps,
who's been very candid
about his own struggles
with depression or Kevin Love
in the NBA, or Naomi Osaka,
the tennis player.
There's less stigma attached to it.
There are still some people who react
with kind of an Old-School reaction, hey,
an athlete never quits.
Tough it out.
I think that there's an evolution now
in our understanding and empathy
for these situations,
and it's moved forward
by those prominent athletes
who are willing to acknowledge
their own circumstances publicly.
Yeah, good for them.
Bob Costas, thank you. Great to see you.